des millions de canadiens on le sait
sont en télétravail depuis le début de
la pandémie et ils ont droit à certaines
déductions fiscales mais quelles sont
elles alors pour y voir plus clair je
reçois sarah phaneuf
elle est associé en fiscalité au cabinet
raymond chabot grant thornton bonsoir
madame pl 9 bon sens commençons par le
début
quels sont les critères qui qualifie un
employé de télétravailleurs en terme
fiscal mais en fait il faut savoir qu'il
existe déjà des réalités déjà avant 2020
des rallyes pour permettre à certains
salariés qui travaillaient à domicile
parce qu'ils en avaient déjà elle de
déduire certain montant
donc pour pouvoir le faire il fallait
rencontrer l'une de deux conditions donc
soir que notre travail parce que notre
principal du notre domicile pardon
constituent notre principal lieu de
travail
donc on y travaille à plus de 50% ou au
travail à la maison dans un endroit qui
est uniquement réservé notre travail et
qui nous ça va rencontrer des clients
sur une base régulière et continue donc
c'était des critères le quitter en place
et au delà de ça on doit retenir de
notre employeur un formulaire où tant
fédéral que québec vous qui vient
attester que notre employeur nous
demande de travailler donc la maison et
d'assumer les dépenses qui en découlent
donc ce sont les règles et standards
s'appliquent et déjà avant mais qui
cette année vont fort probablement
appliquée à de nombreux canadiens qui me
répondent aisément 3 et est ce que des
règles madame phaneuf qui ont changé
justement en raison de la coved 19h01
certain assouplissement par kapo stop
bar du fédéral fait que quand on parle
de l'ue principal de travail ce qui
existe et qu'on regarde et on regarde
sur une année complète
maintenant ils ont eu à assouplir cette
mesure là pour lui retenu en tenir
compte du fait que les personnes ne
reconnaissent pas on a travaillé toute
l'année à domicile donc dans la mesure
où pour une période de temps on aura
travaillé a plus que 50 % à notre maison
donc on se représente lui pour cette
période de rencontrer les critères et
pouvons déduire les dépenses pour cette
période
alors si on travaille à la maison depuis
la mi mars en grande partie ou en
totalité quel sac seront doigts
commencent à mettre de côté en prévision
justement de la prochaine déclaration
ce qui nous plaît parce que c'était en
comme un homme dépense donc ce sont
principalement les fournitures qui font
consommer dans notre travail donc on
peut penser au crayon - la papeterie un
langue pour pour l'imprimante donc la
marque on utilise pour pour notre
travail et au delà de ça on peut déduire
qu'une dépense qui sont directement
relié à notre domicile mais ça va être
seulement électricité chauffage les
produits de nettoyage par exemple les
réparations mineures qu'on pouvait faire
à notre à notre bureau qui est utilisée
là à la maison et donc ce sont vraiment
des dépenses locales pourront déduire
qu'en pourcentage de l'utilisation qu'on
fait notre de notre domicile pour notre
travail est donc en fonction de la super
flic est utilisé pour notre bureau
versus la superficie totale
donc on doit faire le calcul la spire ci
qui est utilisé pour le bureau
finalement exactement si on est
locataire et son est propriétaire aussi
c'est différent la seule nuance c'est
que le qatar non plus ne dépense que les
nouveaux nommés va pouvoir déduire en
fonction toujours du même pourcentage
une partie de son loyer alors que le
propriétaire lui ne payant pas de loyer
de ne pourra pas déduire un tel débat si
on travaille par exemple on a vu ça au
chalet ou sur la terrasse l'été est ce
que ça ça compte pour les déductions
c'est la même logique donc pour y aller
toujours selon l'idée c'est qu'il faut
que les dépenses soient raisonnables et
qui sont établis en fonction
on utilise pour notre travail donc ça
peut représenter quel montant par
exemple au bout d'une année pour un
travailleur de la classe moyenne
justement qu'est salariés c'est souvent
pas des montants aussi importants
justement due au fait que notre bureau
représente parfois des quinze vingts
pour cent de la propriété ils n'ont pas
l'entièreté et contrairement aux
travailleurs autonomes les salariés ne
peuvent pas prendre de décisions pour ce
qui taxe municipale taxes scolaires les
assurances des intérêts hypothécaires et
ce sont souvent ces monts par le son qui
sont les plus importantes donc ça
demeure quand même une réduction qui
sont limitées mais son look 100
accessible qui ne l'étaient pas un
instrument paravent pour plusieurs
oui il faut s'intéresser bien sûr à ceux
pour le savoir on a vu des conjoints par
exemple qui les deux sont contraints au
télétravail comment ça fonctionne parce
que c'est ce qu'ont choisi un des deux
conjoints ou est-ce qu'on peut les deux
faire les demandes de déductions par
exemple mais les bus peuvent prendre une
toute somme est toujours en fonction de
leur propre situation donc si chacun
utilise une pierre de la maison mais
chacun rétablir chantage à déterminer
quelles dépenses sont déductibles et
s'ils utilisent par exemple la même
pièce ne le font de répartir les
dépenses l'idée étant qu'on ne peut pas
déduire la même dépense de jouer voilà
vous disiez tout à l'heure que ça
prenait depuis toujours une attestation
de télétravail de la part de l'employeur
bon je le disais d'entrée de jeu il ya
près de 3 millions sinon plus pro
millions de canadiens qui ont été
contraints à rester au travail à la
maison en fait que travailler à la
maison
est-ce qu'on va demander encore une fois
ce document là d'après vous pour la
prochaine déclaration d'impôts à ce jour
je obligé de répondre oui on se sent que
les autorités du calen son contraire par
contre vraiment beaucoup de
représentations qui ont été faits à
auprès des autorités fiscales d'accorder
une certaine technicité pour cette année
exactement pour la raison que vous non
parce que en 2018 selon statistique
canada indique 75 mais le canadien avait
bénéficié justement déduction donc ça
pourrait être vraiment beaucoup plus
importantes cette année non exactement
et des employeurs qui ne complétait plus
jamais ces formulaires leur pourrait se
retrouver dans une situation où ils
devront produire en a plusieurs
alors c'est vraiment un dossier très
intéressant qui concerne beaucoup de
monde merci beaucoup madame phaneuf
je connais une bonne soirée au revoir